stimmabgabe in besonderen zeiten die
kommunalwahlen in nordrhein westfalen
gelten auch als test für die ambitionen
von ministerpräsident armin laschet
feuer außer kontrolle an der
amerikanischen westküste sterben immer
mehr menschen in den größten waldbränden
die die region je erlebt hat und mut auf
den straßen trotz brutaler
polizeimethoden lassen sich die
demonstranten in belarus nicht stoppen
[Musik]
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievert in allen an diesem
sonntag zehn minuten für die nachrichten
im überblick und kristin otto schaut
nachher auf den sport wandertag und wir
beginnen mit der größten wahl in
deutschland in diesem jahr mit der
kommunalwahl in nordrhein westfalen die
ist nicht nur für das einwohnerstärkste
bundesland bedeutend sondern könnte auch
signalwirkung haben für den bund ihre
stimme abgeben durften rund 14 millionen
menschen in diesen corona zeiten taten
das besonders viele per brief es ist
eine spannende wahl die grünen hoffen in
bonn und aachen erstmals das
stadtoberhaupt zu stellen und die cdu in
dortmund landesweit liegen bei
kommunalwahlen in nrw seit gut 20 jahren
die christdemokraten vorne dass das
jetzt wieder so ist hofft
ministerpräsident armin laschet die wahl
sehen viele auch als stimmungstest für
den möglichen kanzlerkandidaten in der
union
und wir gehen jetzt live in die
landeshauptstadt nach düsseldorf zur
torte ferber genannt dort wie sieht's
denn jetzt aus ließ der erste überblick
dieser war nach der ersten prognose ist
die cdu der wahlgewinner 36 prozent das
wäre etwas weniger als bei der letzten
kommunalwahl da war die cdu allerdings
noch inland in der opposition
für die spd ist es ein debakel muss man
sagen die prognose bei 23,5 prozent das
wäre das schlechteste
kommunalwahlergebnis ihrer geschichte
und je droht zudem noch der verlust
prestigeträchtige rathäuser wir haben es
gehört dortmund seit 74 jahren in spd
hand
die grünen könnten ebenfalls ein großer
wahlgewinner sein
sie haben vermutlich das beste
kommunalwahlergebnis ihrer geschichte in
19 prozent und fdp fdp und linke haben
alle so ungefähr um die fünf prozent
da ist also noch ein bisschen muss man
noch abwarten was ich dort ergibt im
laufe des abends jetzt ist das
kommunalwahlen in nrw aber was lässt
sich daraus ableiten für ganz
deutschland
nun es kommt darauf an auf welcher seite
man steht die gewinner werden jetzt
sicherlich sagen dass sie verspüren
rückenwind für berlin das dürfte für die
cdu und auch für die grünen gelten bei
der
spd und vermutlich auch bei der fdp wird
es wohl eher heißen nun das sind
kommunalwahlen da weiß man noch nicht so
ganz genau was da raus für den bund
resultieren können das wird
heruntergespielt werden
in einigen städten ist auch noch nicht
klar was daraus wird armin laschet der
wird jetzt schon gleich vor die presse
treten
obwohl man noch nicht weiß welche
rathäuser die cdu dann tatsächlich hat
es gibt stichwahlen in zwei wirken und
das auch in seiner heimatstadt arten
voraussichtlich dort liegen übrigens die
grünen vorne
dr seit der schlüssel dorf ganz
herzlichen dank für diese ersten
informationen und wenn sie weitere
ergebnisse hintergründe und
einschätzungen zur kommunalwahl in nrw
suchen dann bietet ihnen die zdf- heute-
app den kompletten überblick
so und jetzt in der sendung gucken wir
auf die gemeldeten neuinfektionen in
deutschland die sind weiter nur leicht
gestiegen
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1390 menschen mit dem
virus angesteckt gestern waren es 1350
das ist aber nur ein wert der aussagen
macht über die korona entwicklung dazu
gehört auch dass es laut lka im moment
viele jüngere betrifft es nur
vergleichsweise wenig schwere
erkrankungen gibt und vergleichsweise
wenig todesfälle und jetzt eine
personalie gerd müller bundesminister
der csu für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung will sich
aus der politik zurückziehen und bei der
bundestagswahl im nächsten jahr nicht
mehr kandidieren
damit will müller wie er sagt einen
generationenwechsel ermöglichen zuletzt
hatte er gefordert deutschland müsse
mehr migranten aus dem abgebrannten
lager moria aufnehmen während die
politik weiter über eine mögliche
verteilung der migranten diskutiert
haben die ersten von ihnen jetzt wieder
ein notdürftiges dach überm kopf auf
lesbos bis zum abend sollen 1000
menschen untergebracht sein
die lage bleibt jedoch angespannt da
sich viele flüchtlinge weigern wieder in
ein zeltlager gebracht zu werden
griechenlands ministerpräsident fordert
von der eu eine neue migrationspolitik
in den usa kämpfen zehntausende helfer
weiter gegen die extremen feuer die zahl
der todesopfer ist gestiegen auf
mindestens 31
eine fläche so groß wie mecklenburg
vorpommern ist zerstört betroffen ist
die pazifikküste im westen der usa es
brennt in den staaten washington oregon
und kalifornien an so vielen stellen und
so stark dass der rauch sogar aus dem
all zu sehen ist ines trams familie
sojus gräbt in schutt und asche nach dem
was übrig ist von ihrem zuhause in
oregon an der grenze zu kalifornien als
die flammen zu nah kamen packten sie das
nötigste und flohen
es sieht nach so wenig aus wie noah hat
unser gesamtes leben in diesen kleinen
stadtwerke passt die verheerendsten
brände an der us-westküste seit
menschengedenken rauch und asche
verdunkeln den himmel
eine halbe million menschen auf der
flucht vor den flammen und schlechter
luft
ich muss nicht ständig husten aber
morgens müsse ich einen schwarzen
schleim hoch starke winde dürre und
hitze trockenes unterholz verantwortlich
für waldbrände schlimmer als man sie
bislang hier erlebt hat mehr feuer auf
einer größeren fläche
kaliforniens gouverneur appelliert an
alle klimawandel skeptiker auch
präsident trump das haben die
wissenschaftler ein halbes jahrhundert
exakt vorhergesagt es ist jetzt da
kalifornien liebe leute wird bald ganz
amerika sein was wir hier erleben wird
gemeinden überall in den usa heimsuchen
wenn wir den klimawandel nicht in den
griff kriegen
feuer und zerstörung scheinen eine
ständige realität zu werden entlang der
westküste amerikas die waldbrandsaison
2020 sie hat gerade erst begonnen
in belarus auch an diesem sonntag neue
massenproteste die menschen lassen sich
von den verhaftungen und dem brutalen
vorgehen der regierung nicht abschrecken
ihnen gegenüber ein großaufgebot von
sonderpolizei
und armee zehntausende fordern den
rücktritt von staatschef alexander
lukaschenko für begann berichtet
zu den besonderheiten der proteste in
belarus gehört dass sie das ganze land
erfasst haben
in der kleinstadt show dino
demonstrieren ein paar dutzend gegen die
regierung ein polizist schlägt zu in
brest fordern tausende lukaschenko
rückzug sicherheitskräfte antworten mit
wasserwerfern und durch minsk schalen
regimekritische sprechchöre die
freilassung aller politischer gefangenen
und wir fordern dass man uns nicht wie
idioten behandelt die demokratiebewegung
hatte heute zum marsch der helden
aufgerufen gewidmet der inhaftierten
oppositionsführerin kalaschnikow und
zahlreichen weiteren politischen
gefangenen
ich will nicht unter einem diktator
leben wir machen weiter unser ganzes
leben lang bis er aufgibt wir wollen
nicht zu kampfhandlungen wechseln wir
wollen friedlich unsere macht ausüben
stunden vor beginn der kundgebung
uniformierte und stacheldraht in der
innenstadt das internet wird zeitweise
gestört diejenigen die sich einen
demokratischen neuanfang wünschen ziehen
dennoch durchs herz der belarussischen
hauptstadt
morgen trifft präsident lukaschenko
wladimir putin im russischen sotchi dass
er die lage in seinem land im griff habe
wird lukas renko angesichts der
andauernden proteste und festnahmen
schwerlich behaupten können
und jetzt machen anstrich und soll die
nachrichten zunächst und gucken rüber
zum sonntag sport so christi den hammer
knackig gebündelt turbulent und
chaotisch der neunte wm-lauf der formel
1 in mugello das insgesamt tausendste
rennen für ferrari kein highlight der
große preis der toskana endete nach
unfällen und zwei unterbrechungen mit
einem doppelerfolg für die silberpfeile
selbst der sieger lewis hamilton völlig
geschafft kaum imstande seinen erfolg
vor teamkollege potters spontan zu
feiern nach solchen szenen
massenkarambolage nach einem restart die
hinteren fahrer geben zu früh vollgas
rasen in das stehende wagen aufatmen
alle unversehrt sowie später nach reifen
defekt bei tempo 280 auch racing-pilot
stoll der drittplatzierte von monza
sebastian vettel wird zehnter und ist
damit immerhin mal wieder in den punkten
im tausendsten rennen von ferrari zwei
plätze hinter teamgefährte le claire die
japanerin naomi osaka hat zum zweiten
mal in ihrer noch jungen tennis karriere
die us open gewonnen
die 22 jährige besiegte in new york
victoria azarenka aus belarus mit 1 zu 6
6 3 und 6 2 3 am abend bestreitet
alexander zverev gegen dominique team
aus österreich
das herren-finale zu 15 meter bei der
tour de france mit drei schweren
anstiegen im jura sieger bei der extrem
steilen bergankunft nach 175 kilometern
der slowene ta dp jha vor seinem
landsmann dem mann in gelb primor
schrott stuhr vorjahresgewinner egern
bernal weit abgeschlagen morgen ist
ruhetag und speerwerfer johannes vetter
ist auch beim istaf in berlin eine
weltklasse leistung gelungen eine woche
nach seinem 97 meter wurf flug diesmal
sein speer 87 meter 26 weit ein
ungefährdeter triumph und erfolgreiche
abschluss dieser ungewöhnlichen corona
saison und weiter keine überraschung im
dfb-pokal wobei sich hoffenheim als
erstligist erst im elfmeterschießen bei
viertligist chemnitz durchsetzen konnte
kristin vielen dank so jetzt lohnt es
sich noch schnell aufs wetter zu gucken
denn das wird
wieder viel sonne haben und nur wenige
harmlose wolken die temperatur steigt
auf 24 bis 32 grad
und genau so hochsommerlich geht es bis
mittwoch weiter am dienstag sind sogar
34 grad möglich
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal um
21.45 mit dem kollegen claus kleber und
weiteren ergebnissen der kommunalwahl in
nrw morgen freut sich an dieser stelle
barbara hahlweg auf sie